40 countries fewer than a third of all
signatories to the international
criminal court gathered in London
affirming their support for the Court's
work in Ukraine
the journey towards International
Justice will be long its scope vast and
these mainly Western members of the
Court have pledged money and resources
to the cause we share the belief that
President Putin and The Wider leadership
must be held to account and it's
absolutely vital that we unite behind
the ICC and that we support the office
of the prosecutor with whatever it needs
appealing for support the icc's chief
prosecutor said the very concept of
international Justice was at stake if we
don't at this moment in world affairs
cling to the law if we don't look at
ourselves and decide how we can do
better not just in Ukraine but as
Nations as member states of the United
Nations we will not only miss an
opportunity but we may not have further
opportunities hi on everyone's agenda
was the first major step on that Journey
arrest warrants issued last week for
Russian President Vladimir Putin and his
children's rights commissioner charged
with the illegal deportation of
Ukrainian children
Russia's response a day after President
Putin toured the Ukrainian city of
mariopol now under Russian occupation
was to issue criminal charges against
the ICC itself for ignoring Putin's
immunity as Head of State under
international law
so the chief prosecutor of the ICC
Kareem Khan has urged countries here to
find the stamina to deliver
International justice but the real test
of that stamina will not be in pledges
made at conferences like these but in
countries signed up to the ICC
recognizing their obligation to deliver
on its orders in the name of
international Justice
like South Africa a signatory to the ICC
which failed to arrest Sudan's Omar
Hassan al-Bashir on an ICC warrant when
he visited the country in 2015.
President Putin is due there for a
summit in August and the South African
presidency says it is aware of its legal
obligations
Mr Putin may have to rethink his plans
now a wanted man in the international
criminal courts Quest For Justice Jonah
Al Jazeera London